[Music]
these people haven't washed their hair
for weeks months and sometimes years
now with the right techniques
some results are better than others but
if you decided to stop washing your hair
forever what could happen to you
could this be good for your hair
[Applause]
how could this lead to a skin infection
and how long could you go before things
got
really nasty
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you never washed your hair
believe it or not there can be some
benefits to not washing your hair
depending on your lifestyle and hair
type you can have a healthier scalp and
locks
so if you want to go for a couple of
days without washing go for it
just make sure you're comfortable and
that it doesn't smell
but
what would happen if you didn't wash
your hair for a couple of weeks
if you're the kind of person who doesn't
sweat a lot and doesn't have oily hair
this might be a good thing for you
some say your hair could become thicker
and more voluminous after several weeks
of not washing it
but if you kept this going for a couple
of months
well
that might be a different story
you might be saving some time and money
on this no shampoo plan but you'll also
be gaining some funky smells
that's because your hair is trapping
moisture allowing bacteria to build up
on your unwashed scalp
this is due to the thick layer of sebum
being produced on your scalp
usually this stuff is good as its
natural oil that keeps your hair
moisturized and healthy
but too much of it is some seriously bad
news
this thick layer of oil would give you a
funky moldy smell after months worth of
dirt and bacteria get attached to your
scalp
you might also have to get acquainted
with some oil loving fungus that could
leave you with some nasty skin
conditions
and if that weren't enough you'd have a
tough time touching your scalp after
just a couple of months
it would be way too sensitive and
painful
so say goodbye to ponytails
and as you're closing in on a year of
this awful journey the dirt would
continue to build up
you'd be smellier and dirtier than ever
as your scalp and hair follicles would
be clogged with tons of dried up oil
bacteria dirt and possible fungal
diseases
luckily you probably wouldn't have to
pay for a haircut
since your follicles are so clogged your
hair would stop growing and if you
stopped brushing you'd likely have a
messy clump of smelly hair attached to
your head
this would be incredibly uncomfortable
painful and would probably have you
losing friends due to the smell
as you kept going past one year
there's a good chance you could lose all
your hair entirely due to the bacteria
on your scalp
eventually you'd be left with no hair at
all with a damaged and itchy scalp
that's bound to have some serious skin
infections
so although it might take a couple of
extra minutes in the shower you should
definitely be washing your hair
now everyone's hair is different
depending on your hair type and proper
care you could go for days or weeks
without shampoo
sometimes it can be beneficial
just go with what feels right for you
if it smells and feels dirty after a day
wash it
if it feels clean after a week
don't worry about it
you know there are other things you
should be washing every day though
and those are your teeth
what would happen if you stopped
brushing your teeth
[Applause]
well
that's a story
for another
what if